Film Courage: Larry why do you feel that BEETLEJUICE
sold?
Why did the screenplay sell (in your opinion)?
Larry Wilson: You know…this is going to
sound so pretentious.
But when I decided I was going to be a writer
again and decided I was going to do it with
Michael [McDowell].
In my mind I said to myself…(this sounds
so awful maybe) but “I’m going to write
a classic.
I’m not just going to write another movie.
We are going to going to create a classic.”
And who knows what that means?
I know it sounds obnoxious.
But we knew probably…I don’t know…some
20 pages in that just something was happening.
And we weren’t thinking about demographics.
We weren’t thinking about who the audience
was going to be.
We weren’t thinking about any “commercial”
aspects of it.
We were thinking What’s good?
What’s funny?
What’s moving the story forward?
What are the zaniest, craziest ideas we could
have.
And it happens with scripts and it happens
in your writing.
There are just times that you feel that you’re
in a zone and place that you are so connected
with yourself.
And you are so connect with what your vision
is, that if you can get it on a page, other
people are going to see it and feel it to.
And that movie as that.
We didn’t know what was going to happen
with it.
When the movie was finished there were people
at Warner Brothers in the marketing department
that absolutely hated it.
They wanted to change the title the HOUSE
GHOST and dump it.
And back in the days when you’d put it in
a thousand theaters and let it run a week
and hopefully it would go away.
That wasn’t everyone and we had David Geffen
on our side so we were protected but it was
hardly loved but I knew who we were writing
it for in my mind.
This is a very 80’s reference…there was
a band (there is still a band) The Cure, The
(great) Cure (a band I loved).
And I had gone to see them at the [Pasadena]
Rosebowl.
A huge concert (maybe 50,000 people).
And it felt to me that it was 50,000 teenage
girls in black!
Film Courage: I was probably one of them!
I was into The Cure [Laughs].
Larry Wilson: Right!
And the Winona Ryder character “Lydia”
came out of that.
And I always thought that’s who the audience
for this movie is as we were writing it.
That for me (and maybe for Michael) that was
who I thought this movie was being written
for.
And it’s really a family story and it’s
really about a girl who needs a mom and a
dad because her real mom and dad don’t understand
her and don’t spend enough time with her
so she ends up with two ghosts.
That’s the heart of the movie and that is
what I was writing toward.
So finally it’s released and I go to see
it, nearby where we are sitting now at Universal.
It’s a Friday night.
It’s the the first Friday night.
And I watch it with the first audience (a
real audience for the first time).
Of course there had been some test audiences.
And people are coming out of it either loving
it or hating it which I thought “Great!
That’s exactly what we wanted.”
And that was Friday night.
Then Saturday night I went back and saw a
bunch of teenage girls who had gone into their
closet (having seen in on Friday night) and
came back dressed like Winona Ryder [the character
Lydia Deetz].
And I thought “Okay.
It’s a hit!
We have connected with the audience to the
point where there are already dressing up
as Lydia.”
And then there was a marketing meeting at
Warner Brothers (it may have been on a Monday).
And it had surpassed everyone’s expectations
in terms of the grosses and the audience feedback.
And it was obvious that it was going to take
off and be something special.
And again in this “no-name zone” [Laughs]…there
was this marketing person who was a guy who
I remember would wear a scarf no matter what
the temperature was, okay?
And I remember Tim Burton being there and
David Geffen being there, “The Michaels,’
and myself.
And this marketing person, all he could say,
the best he could do was say “Well, at least
we got the little girls in black to come see.”
And we walk out of the meeting and Tim said
“Well, who the “F” did he think we made
it for?”
[Laughs].
And when things are going well in my writing
(and I think it’s true for all writers),
if you are intensely self-conscious about
who is your audience, who is…”is this
for the 12 to 16-year-olds?”
If you’re doing that you are not writing
well.
And you get in a zone and your story starts
telling you.
You are not telling the story.
It’s emerging from some place within you.
And that’s what BEETLEJUICE was and I used
to say to Michael sometimes because I could
feel it going well and I’d say “Michael,
you know we’re going to have a toy line.”
And he’d say “Shut up!
Shut up!
Let’s just finish the script.”
You know?
But it’s a very hard thing to explain.
It’s an epiphany after epiphany and you
feel like you’re just onto something bigger
than you.
Film Courage: Well going back to the other
“no-name person,” did they ever reach
out to you [after the success of BEETLEJUICE].
Here they put you in a spot that you’re
almost on a ledge (metaphorically).
And you’re just elated with validation that
this worked (maybe you didn’t totally expect
it).
But did that person ever reach out to you?
Larry Wilson: No…because that would have
required a certain amount of humility and
a certain willingness to say “You know what,
I guessed wrong on this one.”
And not everyone has that ability.